in a string of now deleted tweets kanye
west claims his wife kim kardashian and
her mom kris jenner
were trying to lock him up now a source
tells e.t that the 39 year old reality
star
is completely devastated here's what
went down
the 43 year old rapper called out his
wife and mother-in-law in a series of
tweets on monday night
writing chris don't play with me you and
that calmie
are not allowed around my children y'all
tried to lock me up
calmier is seemingly a reference to kris
jenner's longtime beau
corey gamble kanye whose oldest child
with kim
is seven-year-old daughter north
continued tweeting
put my life the line so north's mother
would never sell her sex rape
another tweet read i put my life on my
god that north's mom would never
photograph her doing playboy
and that's on god kanye also shared that
he was at the family's ranch in wyoming
adding
come and get me before requesting that
chris and kim
call me now meanwhile a source tells e.t
that kim has been trying to get kanye
help for his recent episode
but he's refused it quote kim has always
been public about everything in her life
but with kanye and him being bipolar she
has always respected to keep that more
private and within the family
the source adds that kim is completely
devastated that kanye is tweeting about
the family
and painting her as trying to lock him
up adding that she only ever wants the
best for her husband
i've seen him go through a lot and he's
just the most
genuine person and you know he might say
things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart
of course all of this follows kanye's
emotional speech on
sunday at his first political rally in
south carolina
where yay broke down in tears telling
the crowd that his dad wanted his mom to
have an abortion when she was pregnant
with him
my mom saved my life my dad wanted to
abort me
kanye also claimed he considered an
abortion when kim
was pregnant with north even if my wife
were to divorce me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to she stood up
and she protected that child
on monday a source told et that kim was
upset about kanye's speech
adding quote she knows this is something
north will see when she gets older
and that's heartbreaking both kim and
kanye have been candid in recent years
about his battle with bipolar disorder
there's some cases of bipolar where
people go low i'm
i'm one that goes high kanye opened up
about it on jimmy kimmel live in 2018.
so you don't have extreme periods of of
depression
oh no no oh no because i just say it
i'll say on real tv like oh i thought
about kevlar and then the thought is
gone you know
and in 2019 kim talked about her
husband's condition in vogue's may
issue quote it is an emotional process
for sure
right now everything is really calm but
we can definitely feel episodes coming
and we know how to handle them